do you agree with magnus's decision to
Forfeit the match his most recent match
with Hans oh tough question I I don't
in my heart of hearts I feel like there
had to be a better way to handle it than
what Magnus did
um on the other hand sort of being in
this world of top Grand Masters having
heard these rumors for two years I think
that the fact that it was blown off and
it wasn't treated seriously I'm not sure
if there was a better option so my heart
of hearts I feel like there had to be a
better way to handle it but in
practicality like in the Practical world
I don't I think he might have made the
only decision where it became a big
issue
yeah I mean I guess I would have loved
to see just where 100 it's certain that
there's no cheating involved that they
play a bunch of games
yeah I think there was actually an
article that was released today by uh
Ken rogoff who is a grand master at
chess where he wrote this article in the
Boston Globe and he essentially said
that like have Hans and Magnus play a
match and see what his score is because
statistically if it's above a certain
percentage that means he's legitimate
because of course you have security
um if it's below that might mean that
probably means that he's not at the
level
um that he's at so I don't know if
that's a real way to settle it
necessarily
um because also for Magnus to ask him to
play against someone who's cheated I
think for him he just he would never
entertain the idea because it's like why
am I going to play against someone who
cheated so yeah I don't I don't know
it's very tough and you know one one
other thing I would say on the topic
that's really important to note is this
sort of came from from left field for
most people who are in the general
public or very casual chess players but
this is not something that wasn't known
wasn't even on the radar I think this
has not been said before but there's
there's one of these things where they
talk about how Hans has uh he's he
played better during a period of time
when he games were broadcast versus not
broadcast I actually heard this rumor
two years ago during during one of the
terms he's playing specifically so that
is the thing is that this has been out
there for a very long time and so it's
hard because you do believe that Magus
could have handled it better but if it
was two years of these rumors and
nothing was done about it I don't know